so this is work that was done in
collaboration with AT&T Labs it's a very
practical piece of work so it's the
principle author is here siddharth said
patty and also super team Deb and her
yarn from AT&T Labs okay so the problem
is one where we are given lots of error
messages from a network and you have to
figure out what error events contributed
to this error messages okay and I'll
explain further so this is probably
applicable to any kind of distributed
data center setting but I'm going to
primarily focus on a data center network
that supports wireless networks
everybody knows what a data center is a
data center is a large collection of
servers it's used by all the major
companies that you can think of these
days and the data center network is a
network of these data centers so each
one of these is the picture that I
showed in the previous page and they're
all interconnected there they're
geographically distributed and they're
interconnected in some fashion so
normally when you think of distributed
data center networks you think of Amazon
Google Facebook and so on but it's also
used by banks and it's also used by AT&T
with whom we collaborated on this
project and Verizon Sprint and and/or
the all major wireless service providers
so how does AT&T use distributed data
center networks so normally when you
think of wireless network you think of a
cell phone which is trying to access
some base stations and so on but
supporting this wireless network there
is actually a distributed data center
network in the background okay and it
does a lot of things that I'm going to
give a very very simple examples of what
it does but it does a lot lot more than
what I'm going to explain here so as an
example let's say my postdoc Waena who's
been visiting Simon's Institute with me
she's normally in Illinois and she's
making a phone call from California so
there is a piece of software that's
sitting in some data center here you can
call it a virtual machine and it sends a
message
to a database in Illinois to
authenticate whether this is really
wayna has she paid her bill has she
exceeded her voice call limit has she
exceeded her data limit all of these are
done actually before he complete the
phone call okay and this this message
from this data center might have to be
routed through some internet router to
some other data center here and then
from there goes to the data center in
Illinois
okay so what happens if there's a
failure if there's a router failure here
okay so then the network generates many
messages at various locations in the
network so there's one message it says
that the routers fan is broken down okay
oh and and this this data center would
realize the the the data center in
Illinois would realize that its
connection to the Colorado data center
is is no longer functioning and the
California data center would generate a
message saying that I'm not able to
validate if this is wayna for example
okay so so these are the messages that
are generated due to this router failure
and similarly somebody else another one
of my students Hirsch is calling Joseph
whose happens to be here and and let's
say there is a loose connection in a
line card which may not even generate an
error message by itself but but it the
harshest call to Joseph cannot complete
because of them some some unknown error
in the network so that also gets entered
into this central error law okay
of course here I've color-coded it to
let you know that these red messages are
due to one event and the blue messages
are due to another event what you
actually see just a sequence of messages
okay what you see is just simply a
sequence of messages from this a
sequence of messages you have to figure
out how many events happen in the
network when this event have events
happened and what is the distribution of
messages that each event generates the
probability distribution of messages
that each team in general yes I know the
clock is not that important I mean so
the the messages are sufficiently far
apart that this is not an issue for me
yeah good question yeah so the size of
the data set that I'm dealing with
what-what was given to us by AT&T was a
97 million message set collected over a
50
a period from their network and as I
mentioned this is not most of the
messages are actually generated by VMs
and data centers so is there something
called virtualization we're not familiar
with it it doesn't matter basically
there are more and more software
entities being added to the network each
piece of software is bought from a
different vendor each each one generates
its own error message is not coordinated
there is no you know there's no
standardization of any of these and so
so you get this massive humongous set of
messages that are being generated in the
network and failure and saint-louis
could cause messages from all over the
United States for example okay and the
goal is to take this 97 million message
data set and break it up into events
okay
immense meaning there is one event that
started at 1 second ended at like
thousandth second or whatever and then
you also have to figure out what what is
the distribution of messages that it
generates so we'll make it a little bit
more abstract than it'll be actually
clear what the problem is okay so what's
the modelling so a modeling aspect of
this is so I'm going to assume that each
event generates messages and I'm gonna
call the just color code the messages
I'm going to call them red messages or
green messages or blue messages and so
on so the what I showed earlier was like
a detailed descriptive message but what
we do is we do some natural language
processing on it and then and then
reduce it to a smaller subset of
messages for for reasons that I don't
want to get into so for the purpose of
this talk let's just say that each event
consists of a bunch of messages red
green blue black and so on and each
event has a different distribution over
these messages for example some events
might generate 50 percent of the
messages they might they generate it
generates might be red messages whereas
and 25 percent might be green and 25
percent might be blue whereas another
event might generate 25% red message is
50 percent green messages and 25 percent
blue messages ok so this is what I mean
by an event an event also has a start
time and a finish time during which time
it keeps generating messages according
to some point process some unknown point
process so essentially the way we can
think of this problem is that there's
event one that happened it started here
start at the leftmost point and ended
here and then this event too started in
the middle of event 1
is generating its own set of messages
and what we see in the central error log
is both of these sets of messages merge
together yes no no we don't know
anything so we don't know anything all
we are given is just a bunch of messages
and it's an unsupervised learning
problem there is no expert in AT&T that
knows which of which events generate
which type of messages nothing is all
yeah all we were given it's just a 97
million message data set that's it
nothing is known yeah so in this problem
it's about thousand colors actually and
97 million messages so it's still at
least more than square hundred times the
square of the number of messages so the
number so we are operating I don't know
what maybe I don't know what the
question meant but but if you're asking
the question are we in an
information-rich regime we are I mean
the number of messages is an order of
magnitude smaller than the number of
events if they are roughly equal then
that's a completely different problem
yeah much much sorry number of messages
but different types of messages is much
smaller than the total number of
messages there are like a thousand
different types of messages in the total
number of messages 97 million yes so
during this time there are about 20 or
25 actually over 15 DEP major events
yeah
the network is pretty good I mean it
doesn't fail at often yeah the fan is
broken is an example of an event but
that's not what what machine learning is
going to tell us and that that's usually
it's not that it's not that type of
event as I mentioned because of
virtualization all you're going to know
is that this piece of software is not
going to be was not able to talk with
another piece of software could be all
kinds of errors it could be a hardware
error could be software mostly the
software errors okay so all they're
interested in is figuring out what
distribution of I mean by event what I
mean is a distribution of our messages
that's it I just want I'll so that final
answer they want is I have five types of
or 15 types of events event of events of
type one produce you know this type of
messages or this distribution of
messages
and then the idea is that they are I
don't know if I'm allowed to say this
but when I'm being recorded but I'm
going to say it they are they are
interested in operationalizing this
maybe I did this part out and they are
interested in operationalizing this so
the idea is that as as you see a certain
mixture of messages then you can sort of
predictively you know have seen this
problem before
and so maybe perhaps you can take a
corrective action yeah yeah well
actually they're only 25 events 97
million messages
yeah that's pretty information rich
regime right so so the point is that a
single event just you know creates
messages all over the network that is
the big difficulty here the enormity of
the message logs the problem and that is
just yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly there's
just a massive number of messages that
each event causes because a massive
massive network I mean I don't even know
how many routers and how many base
stations or how many optical fibers are
involved in this yeah so we have at
least three or four sometimes yeah yeah
but of course there are lots of times
that there is no messages yes I mean
there nothing happens in the network I
mean it's collected over yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's how that's how it should be
right yeah yes that is our assumption
and it does yeah yeah we validated in
various different manner because this is
an unsupervised learning problem it's
kind of hard to validate depending on
the time I'll talk about how we
validated yeah
no no not that all of these are good
questions what's that exactly that's
right that's right and and roughly
speaking this is borne out in the in the
message set and the reason is I think
during the occurrence of an event so
many different types of what do I mean
functionalities are carried out in the
same set of functionalities happen in
the network over and over and over every
time somebody initiates a call or maybe
there's a power control algorithm
running in the data center which
actually computes you know the the power
control parameters for the 4G network
for example so exactly the same set of
functionalities are executed over and
over and every time it tries to execute
it it's going to generate a message and
so we see the same thing over and over
yeah good question yes there's not a
sequential prom this is given to us this
is an offline problem so the sequential
problems once we have done this what
they are trying to do is use this
information to figure out as messages
are being generated in the network to
see if this is something we have seen
before and what did we do at that time
yes okay okay so I'm going to make a
complete digression I'm going to talk
about topic modeling and documents and
I'll get back to I'll relate this to our
problems so that is basically the
primary contribution of this work is
basically somehow convert our problem to
a topic modeling in documents it is a
well studied problem okay so in the
topic modeling problem you are given
multiple documents and you have to
figure out what topics generated these
documents so obviously you know this
this is probably politics this document
probably is about sports and this prob
this is probably a mixture of politics
and sports okay so this is a very famous
algorithm that you know many people I
guess Andrew Eng and Michael Jordan and
and David bleh studied and so in topic
modeling basically at the U you give
these documents
input and the output is basically there
are two topics here of course of course
machine learning will not be able to say
this is sports or this is politics maybe
it will but but basically the output is
basically there are two topics here
document one is generated by topic one
document two is generated by topic two
and document three is a mixture of topic
one and topic two and what a topic is is
just a probability distribution over
words okay this is a well studied
problem if you give if you give
documents to this algorithm called LD a
so LD is a well studied a algorithm so
LD is an algorithm which basically give
it documents it'll output the following
which say this each document is a
probabilistic mixture of certain topics
and each topic is a probability
probabilistic mixture of words okay so I
am going to assume LD a as a black box
so my only goal here is to convert my
problem to document modeling and after
that I'm just going to use off-the-shelf
software to solve the problem it's clear
so I have to figure out so in my model
topics are the same as events words are
what I call events are essentially
topics in document modeling what I call
messages are words in topic in document
modeling but I don't have an ocean of
documents so so what we are going to do
is come up with an efficient algorithm a
linear time algorithm to convert my
problem into this problem in other words
I'm gonna take my message set and break
it up in your documents in linear time
that is basically the contribution here
process if we do some natural language
processing to extract what are called
templates out of is the key important
parts of it and that is slightly
difficult I mean you don't ever work
with actual raw data when you do this
kind of APIs or so you extract the key
features of the messages and there is an
entire NLP thing but you know we just
crudely used
exactly exactly exactly so that's what
the model is the is very important so
basically I'm gonna assume that there
are X types of messages and each each
event is a property distribution over
this messages that's it okay so
basically the idea is what are documents
documents are what I mean so so I'm
going to define something called an
episode which is the equivalent of
documents so if you look at this set of
events there is a transition point here
there's a particular distribution of
messages that happens here because
there's only one event at this point
this distribution changes because there
are two events happening
the first event ends here and so the
distribution messages changes again so
each of these intervals I'm going to
call episodes and these episodes are
going to be like documents in document
modeling okay so the whole problem then
boils down to finding episodes and if
you want to precisely define what an
episode is within each episode the
message distributions are iid within an
episode inter arrival times with
messages I'm going to assume are iid
I'm gonna assume successive episodes
contain different message distributions
and between successive episodes I'm
going to assume that only one new event
starts at one current event ends okay so
this described an episode each message
is generated according to some
probability distribution which is iid
within this episode and then this
distribution changes here so here it
might be 0.5 right 0.25 green and 0.25
something else whereas here it might be
different yeah
okay so the goal is to break up the very
large error log 97 million in our
experiments into episodes and then once
I've done that I'm just going to use LD
so the whole problem is just finding
this episode yes yes so it disappears to
work so you could we have been thinking
whether one could use Markov modeling or
something like that but this works
remarkably well so we haven't done
anything but these are all interesting
problems that we can sort of make up to
work on further but I think for the
problem that we were given this works
very well yeah good question so what is
the algorithm so basically the algorithm
is change point detection I mean this is
should have been obvious essentially
these are points where the distribution
changes okay so that two distributions
involve here one is the inter-arrival
distribution of messages if there are
multiple events occurring messages will
be generated faster and also the
distribution over the messages
themselves are changing well it's a non
parametric change point detection I'm a
classical change point detection you
have you know some hypothesis zero
hypothesis one I mean you you say that
you know at some at at some point there
is a messages or you know generated by
according to some distribution beyond
some point you are given these things
here nothing is given okay so this is a
non parametric change point detection
problem and we want to find an efficient
manner so the whole piece that there are
97 million messages so you can't mean
you have to process all the messages at
least once so it has to be linear time
at least okay but it can't be square of
that I mean you know you just it has to
be small the the complexity has to be
small that is the basic problem here so
the basic idea is that of course you
would guess that there is a change point
at a particular location and then you
estimate the distribution of messages to
the left estimate the distribution of
messages to the right and then you
declare the change point as the point
where the difference is the largest you
sweep through this whole message set and
and and declare that that is the point I
mean of course you might have a
threshold you might say that if this
difference is above a threshold and if
it is maximized at some point you
declare that's the change point but of
course that doesn't work when there
and Kate change points right if their
end messages and K change points the n
choose K possible places where the
change point could could occur and this
is ridiculous complexity you can't you
can't search over over this space so the
question is is there a more efficient
algorithm and we use this idea that was
proposed by Madison and James who used a
different metric and and I'll tell you
what we can't really use their metric
for our problem but we use their
high-level idea so what you do is you
find the change points in hierarchical
fashion so the idea is this so what you
do is you first pretend that there's
only one change point this is not
correct and you pretend that there's
only change point one one change point
find the change point and then divide
the problem into two parts so you look
to the left of the change point that you
found and find more change points and
look to the right of the change point
that you found and look and look for
more change points okay so this is the
this is the idea is this clear is the
algorithm clear okay and in this problem
if you apply this then you detect two
change points and then after that we
apply LD so we've have our documents we
have our words and and we have to
extract topics from this and then we
just apply Lda to this problem and an
Lda will say there was one topic here
two topics here and one topic here okay
and from this you can easily disentangle
and say that there's a topic one started
here and ended here and topic two
started here and ended here or event one
started here and ended here and so on
that's very easy to go after this okay
so from an analysis perspective the main
thing we need to do is I mean showing
that this has a computational complexity
that is order n times M times K is
pretty straightforward I mean that's
pretty straightforward the hard part is
this that is consistency so so what you
need to prove is that when you do this
hierarchical
changepoint detection you have to show
that every time you actually find a true
change point okay the first time you're
pretending there's only one change point
when there are K change point when there
are 20 change points are 25 change point
you pretend that there's only one okay
and and you have to show that when you
do this you actually find
change point and if you when you
hierarchically do this actually find all
the change points and what we do is what
we show is that the the normalize change
point if there are n messages and tau
one had is the location of the
first-stage point in a relative sense
that one had divided by n is the
location of the first change point what
you show is that we show consistency
result in the limit as n goes to
infinity all the change points are
detected exactly so there are notes for
es change points when you when you
execute this algorithm okay that's the
first result the proof of this may be a
skip it essentially the idea is that
yeah it's a somewhat involved proof I
mean this is the main difficult part of
the proof is somewhat involved proof
showing that you have consistency okay
so so you don't get sporty exchange
points the second result is a is a
sample complexity result which tells you
how many samples do you need to get all
the change points to some within some
detect all the change points with
probability greater than some one minus
beta and that again now it's you know
this part this is actually relatively
straightforward because essentially
you're estimating probability
distribution so the natural thing to do
is use synapse theorem and then
approximate KL distance by pin squares
in equality and then and then you get
this result okay this is a relatively
easy part I think that consistency part
I think is the harder part of the result
okay so I'm going to talk about
experiments before I wrap it up so
validating this is very very difficult
because there is as I said it's an
unsupervised learning problem so there's
no easy way to validate it so what we do
is we we take the data set and apply
other algorithms which give partial
answers okay and see far if our
algorithm actually matches those answers
in those cases so one simple algorithm
that people use often is clustering type
a clustering type algorithm so basically
you each of the messages can be thought
of as a node in a graph and then you
draw a link between every pair of nodes
and you assign a weight to the to each
link and the weight is one minus the
probability that one might have one mine
is a fraction of
that the red message in the green
message co-occur okay so if this number
is small that means that red and green
co-occur
bye-bye co-occurring what I mean is
first you take the message said and
divide it into smaller bins look at
smaller intervals of time and then so
there are a lot of meta parameters that
you have to deal with in this and these
kind of problems but let's say we can
somehow deal with that and then so you
look at the co-occurrence probability
and a sign of weight and then you look
for and then you remove all ages with
large weights a large weight simply
means that these two messages never
co-occur okay so they're unlikely to be
produced by the same event and then you
look for cliques in this graph and this
is a not exactly the same algorithm that
is used in this context but it's very
similar to other algorithms used in this
context and what we found is that the
list of events found by this message by
this process is the same as so if you
apply this clustering algorithm versus
our algorithm the list of messages
corresponding to each event looks
exactly the same but the clustering
algorithm cannot tell you when an event
started when an event ended okay so
that's that's they need this information
as well and you can also do full
Bayesian inference okay so so so I can
assume that I can assume a generative
model for this whole so I broke it up
into smaller parts called episodes
instead I can do a full-blown Bayesian
inference I could say that events are
generated according to some probability
distribution each events generates
messages according to some distribution
at certain times according to some
distribution and so on then I can do a
maximum likelihood estimation and our
algorithm actually matches there except
that this this maximum likelihood
estimation just is not scalable even for
a very small set of messages we just
looked at 40,000 messages for example
out of this 97 million data set and and
we can see that the amount of time that
it takes just grows humongously just
simply doesn't work okay and but but
again these are two different ways to
validate what we did and we also look to
try to understand our answer visually so
this is again one small segment of the
97 million data set so
x-axis is time and the y-axis is
basically the routers and the y-axis is
just the message-id okay and after we
run our algorithm for this part you can
sort of see that there are 1 2 3 4 5
events here and and 3 of the events are
similar and to I mean they're only two
event types here on the 5-minute events
in this in this in this picture you can
sort of visually see that what you're
doing is is correct because if you look
at so our algorithm says that this and
this are essentially the same event
types and this event type in this event
type are the same you can't see this in
the picture completely because I can't
show you the probability distribution
but the list of messages that these
events generate are are are the same
okay so that's it
so basically our solution to this
problem of detecting events from
messages is to decompose the problem
into two subproblems change point
detection followed by topic modeling and
you can prove that this algorithm has
low computational complexity is probably
consistent and has low sample complexity
and we were able to run this algorithm
on on a data set consisting of 97
million messages and and the way we
validated this is to try to use other
algorithms which either cannot run on
the full data set such as the full
Bayesian inference or clustering which
doesn't give you all the information
that we need but at least all the
information that these various
algorithms provide are consistent with
our algorithm and our algorithm is able
to scale to a massive data set yeah
that's it thank you
yeah it seems to be like a greedy type
thing right you pick in some way the
first change point you say okay oh the
hierarchical algorithm yes yes
the consistency result says that that
works yeah whatever measure this greedy
algorithms minimize it looks like it has
this property that there's a diminishing
return in selection right so at some
point you would stop the algorithm
because there is no you cannot detect
any more change points it seems to be
like some sort of a subset selection
problem with a submodular like cost
function I'm not sure it's more
straightforward than that all it is is
just the probability distribution
changes and you just need to figure out
where it changes and and yes I'm doing
it by apically so you're saying that
there is a maybe there's a different way
to interpret the algorithm okay yeah
yeah yeah possibly yeah here we just
yeah we just looked at consistency and
sample complexity but maybe there's
other ways to interpret it yeah correct
I'm assuming that for the same okay this
is the consistency result is under our
modeling assumption right so so so I'm
going to assume that given and data
points the events happen at tau 1 n time
so tau 1 and tau 1 over N and tau 2 over
N you're right so so you could have a
different model and then you could say
what happened good question I don't have
a good answer to this good question yeah
so you're saying that what if the number
of event scales with the number of with
the number with the amount of data that
you have we haven't thought about that
yeah
yeah okay you mind the mess you into
fixed-size absence then for each app so
just check whether the distribution had
to change so which is roughly what this
clustering algorithm does oh you mean
for the whole thing but then there is so
I guess one of the things is we have
very few meta parameters to tune here
okay so the more and more meta
parameters you have then you have to
also figure out how to tune those
parameters I mean every machine running
out of them will have some parameters
which show something that doesn't have
too many things too - but yeah it's
possible to do other things as well but
you may have to figure out how much that
window should be right yeah that could
be other morals and I think that so the
question was asked there you could also
have some dependence on the messages - I
mean the first as I said we validated
this in many many different ways and it
worked for our data set that's the only
answer that I have I think you can have
more general models and and I think
another interesting question as I said
if the number of messages is roughly of
the same the number of types of messages
is actually after same order as the
number of there are many many problems
that we can make up but for this
particular data set this worked yeah I
don't have anything more to say yeah but
good questions though thank you
[Applause]